a 32-Nanase probably had a reason for cooperating.I
think she stopped me when I was thinking about committing suicide because I was mentally ill, and I became dependent on her.
I'll attract the media as a substitute for chan.I
wonder if it's really going to work out?
If I hadn't
met Mr.
A, I would have been able to get past the
rumors and be happy as usual.  Yes,
Kao is second to none with steel frames
This makes it impossible to confirm your identity by face In
this situation, you can explain that mystery
Why was Karin Nanase pointing directly at the steel frame without even trying to exchange it
[music]
I want to do that, but it's not her.It's because she was someone else who was
hit with steel frames when she
was unconscious.Karima
Nanase, who finished disguising herself at the scene, left
there.
Thank you, I won't return my driver's license. It may
have been necessary to change your attire, but it's relatively easy to make yourself unnoticed
.